si je devais faire un classement des
chansons que j'interprète un peu puis
plus de 30 ans en cinquième position
maîtrise fille a les moyens - pas les
bâillons a les moyens présentés you and
i moyens millions mais tellement fuyant
de dollars ce qui est sensationnel c'est
très passionnel même que on va plus
choisir les bêtises qu'on fait que vous
pour mettre en avant en quatrième
position je mettrais belle créole
[Musique]
c'est un amour de deux espèrent entre
les générations en troisième position je
m'étais invincible
un merci
imprécis
de nous son sens tu parles de la fois
par la croyance en invisible et moi même
qui suis quoi y ont chanté peau
l'éternel aussi c'est quelque chose de
dd pourtant en deuxième position je
mettrais spéciale c'est une chanson ou
vraiment ceux qui tels des passes à sa
sauce en englobant tout ce dont doute
tous tout le potentiel que j'avais c'est
à la fois musical et comédie en première
position alors je mettrais et à
matignicourt et damon des francas on les
a pris
les soul est là qu à dessein
alors il faut toujours rappeler appelé à
la jeunesse d'où ils viennent pour des
outils et modèles
ces matinées contrats nets de valets
contre les pirates là et le riel faut
pas plonger par immonot com comme ce
siècle nous emmène dans le virtuel
alors à la fin classement aujourd'hui
qui pourrait différent demain
quoi qu'il en soit je vous donne rendez
vous le 23 novembre au grand carbet à 20
heures pour résumer tout ça
[Musique]
une
ouais mais là